I'm Troy and I'm so excited not only are
you directing tonight's episode of
Pretty Little Liars you're also
appearing on truth and Eliza afterwards
it's like every form double-dose see
right here it's a serious double dose
yeah I'm shocked that I'm not in in
famous and love like just you can have
three hours of solid me for the first
time ever one Pretty Little Liars
stepped behind the camera in this week's
episode and only et has exclusive
details straight from Troy and Belisario
on her directorial debut tryin I cannot
believe you're episode is finally here I
know it's can't believe it either it's
it's so bizarre because people kept on
as me though look what are you doing
next Tuesday I was like for what they're
like your episode the one that you
directed us like oh my god it's
happening
Oh oh wow I guess I'll be watching it I
don't yeah it's overwhelming
who do you feel like gave you the best
piece of advice before you sat in that
director's chair everyone I didn't try
to like pretend like I knew what I was
doing I asked everyone from Marlene to
Joe to my dad and my mom to my husband
Patrick I have to I happen to be
actually surrounded by directors which
is kind of wonderful and so I was just
like guys give me anything you got and
they all gave me wonderful and very very
different advice what do you tease for
tonight's episode and what does that
Troian spin that you put on it well what
I can definitely tease which is really
fun two things you get to see a little
bit of bad Aria which is really fun
because Lucy her performance was just
amazing she she just went she went there
with them and I was so proud of her and
then um and then also you get Julia
Morris back playing Ren so to get to
open this show you know eight years ago
playing across from him and to get to
close it by directing a scene between
the two of us it was really fun
you